so they're abandoning ship over the
white house because Biden has been
undone by his own party and the clearest
sign is that Ron Klein went how sheep's
stat that guy runs everything has said
he's out of there what's interesting of
course he's running away he'll have some
other high-paying job he'll be
denouncing by within the year
what's interesting is he's replacing him
and of course the rule in this
Administration is you have to pick
someone with a track record of abysmal
failure so needless to say they're
picking the kovid Czar Jeff zience
in case you've forgotten to hear some of
his greatest hits
made important strides in equity
with the majority of booster shots going
to people of color this virus knows no
borders and it's in our national
interest to vaccinate the world bottom
line vaccination requirements work for
the unvaccinated
you're looking at a winter of severe
illness and death
for yourselves your families and the
hospitals you may soon overwhelm
so the guys
humiliating it turned out to be
completely wrong Jeff science had no
background whatsoever medicine he had no
idea what he was talking about
and he never apologized for it so he's
getting an upgrade he's now what else
chief of steppa which interesting is
that Jeff science also got super super
rich now how did a guy like that get so
rich well in just one year 2020 zein's
made between 10 and 28 million dollars
in one year the covid year what
what happened Sean Davis is CEO of the
Federalist he joins us tonight with
possibly some answers Sean thanks so
much for coming on so always the story
is how are these people getting so rich
no one ever asked that question Jeff
science has gotten ritual almost anybody
how do you think that happened
well it's interesting I think especially
through the the covet thing it was a
story we saw all over the country where
I know it's cliche but the rich got
richer and the poor got poorer and zein
seems to have used much of his career
recall he used to be uh the obamacarees
are he oversaw obamacare's
implementation which was also a
government means of enriching uh
pharmaceutical and health care companies
at the expense of the rest of us so
really I think his covet stint was just
the remix of his original uh Obamacare
album
so federal employees have Financial
disclosure forms that the rest of us can
see always the story is who's making
money on these policies that don't help
the public so covid Ukraine that's the
one story The Washington Post never
writes why is that
well I think we know the answer is
because Bezos somehow got even richer
one of the richest people on Earth got
richer during the covet era but but my
favorite excerpt from the Zions
Financial disclosure I don't know if you
saw this you can go look at it at the
White House website he had up to five
million dollars in gold bars listed on
there so he's a real man of the people
well he's got a lot of confidence in the
US dollar I see the government that he
runs issuing this paper that's not worth
anything he's buying gold
ignore what they say watch what they do
Sean Davis thank you for that detail
it's great to see you tonight subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight